abgekackt das heißt wir werden heute abend abkack frei bleiben hoffe ich
nie bei mir in der fritz park steht einfach nur drin synchronisierung nicht möglich oder so was
ne also das sah bei mir jetzt nicht so aus also da stimmt irgendwas synchronisieren nicht möglich
kannst du kann man was sagen während ich laber da ich ungefähr die ausschläge sehen wie laut wir sind
so bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla ja perfekt perfekt reicht schon ich muss noch ein ticken lauter machen
so ich glaube so ist gut so hallo stream auf geht's auf aber strengt ich lasse mich
ein bisschen carry beziehungsweise tilt ist allein einfach zu groß in dem gelb deswegen spielen
wir heute zu zweit was das mal ihr habt jetzt ja lautstärke gehört von mir und von er das passt
das so ist das so ok wir sehen gleich noch mit gelb lautstärke müsste aber passen denke ich
ganz kurz 30 sekunden ja sag mir du wieder da bist dann kann ich dich in weiten
was er ist sehr leise eigentlich müsste also laut meinem obs ist er ungefähr so laut wie ich
aber das können wir gleich noch einstellen das passt feierabend wie das du frag mich jetzt auch
nicht wie ich da drauf komme pommersche aus dem keiner kennt ihr das noch mal hier
und die leute sagen kann du bist leise aber das kann eigentlich überhaupt nicht sein du hast
ungefähr genauso einen ausschlag wie ich das sind obs verstellt wer passt passt du bist
wirklich den ticken lasse ich mache schon mal ein bisschen lauter aber deswegen muss
overwatch leiser sag noch mal bitte was müssen wir nur einmal machen ja so ist besser jungs
oder ist doch besser wo stehst du grad von sr das gleiche wie letzten stream 3000 irgendein
was aber heute wird heute geht's ab also das ist ja ein extra account den ich hierfür für stremen
gemacht habe ich entweite dich sofort ach ich habe das falsche verstellt jetzt müsstest du
ordentlich laut sein sag noch mal bitte was immer diese konfigurationsprobleme ja ist so ist so
schlimm aber jetzt bist du bei mir viel zu laut ach die sind das das das lassen wir jetzt einfach
so will sie da machen das ist eh schlimm dass man das immer so einstellen muss alles dass
das immer so ein immer so ein riesen act ist ok auf geht's nene cake bomb ich entweite ich
sag so leute auf geht's jetzt ich teste ob das muten jetzt funktioniert ich queue mal und mute
mich was denkst du von den sr matchmaking änderungen die bevorstehen also sind schritt in
die richtige richtung denke ich dazu schritt in die richtige richtung allerdings ja nicht genug
denke ich glaube da muss noch ein bisschen mehr kommen es ist ja auch irgendwie absurd dass
aufa watch keine keine team queue hat
sagt man max was hast du für ein smartphone ich habe nach iphone 6
so jetzt gibt es wahrscheinlich zwei stunden queue time
weiß auch nicht was da los ist jetzt jetzt sehe ich aber jetzt bist du ordentlich laut
so was das sein so ist das sehr nice gelte passt so oder chat queue time resident sleeper am
besten sind wenn man sich die queue times in teilweise in englischen streams anguckt
irgendwie als weiß von den von den top 500 leuten irgendwie 45 sekunden und du guckst
dann so um rein elapsen 13 minuten mich würden echt spielerzahlen interessieren oh geht los
die die jemals ausrücken werden ist die frage ja ich habe so meine zweifel soll ich spiel
ich habe aufa watch league geguckt es wird sogar king of the hill zum größten
halt jetzt sen sen und mercy gespielt weil mercy einfach so op ist und wir haben natürlich
keine mercy jetzt dabei ist klar wo stepper den hilfer aus weil weiß nicht keine ahnung
das geht mir als support mehr in so offen sack weißt du du kannst nicht heilen bist
gerade verreckt weil die leute nicht auf dich aufgepasst haben du stehst im spawn aber alle
need healing need healing i need healing so konzentration wow den holen wir uns den holen
wir uns nicht das steht ein router komm auf den punkt auf punkt winston das wars sie
schon mal speed gehen wir mal hinterher nice bomb greetings das habe ich auch meine erfolgsgefühle
kann es in den kannten sticken weil die leute auf damit echt besser geworden sind guck mal
wir spielen genauso gegen den ausgabe 366 dann soll was eine künste zeigen hier mein ziemlich
alleine hatte ich was erwischt ich habe nichts erwischt das ist problem oh mccree on spot
ich habe ulti auf fahrer und spot piste stever wo ist der obligatorische hanso pick
ja der kommt noch heute morgen hatte schon fünf dps team ich war kurz vorm deinstallieren
vorhin den hook gelaufen ich ulte gleich sobald die sobald die on spot kommen wird geultet
aber ich bin nicht da ja jetzt dann muss unser team auch mal was machen
aber geht doch easy clap ging doch ging doch das ist perfekt zum polsport werfen üben
noch mal frage an chat ist lautstärke jetzt ok von uns beiden aber jetzt muss es eigentlich
passen lautstärke von er ist lautstärke von mir ist es eigentlich gut sein in need healing
i need healing lautstärke ist perfekt sagt der chat moment kann es sein dass wir hin
zum team haben wir können uns jetzt überlegen ob wir das spiel wegwerfen sind alle rechts
aber alle und unsere fahrer sich selbst in die luft gesprengt
du bist tot ne ich verpiss mich ich hole euch ab
warum verschwinden deine wats ich glaube die die wats halten plus zwei monate kann das
wir spielen gerade triple support ich gehe gleich roadhog da willst du nur sterben das
wäre nice ja kann sich diese metra mal nützlich machen
was die lau was die ziemlich lau hinter diese komischen säule da wenn du hilfst brauchst
ich bin auf dem spot ich komme ich komme zurück
ich lass mal hier laufen heute ich gucke jetzt nicht in chat während wir im match sind
hinter den saria hast du noch gekriegt die barriere wenn du noch lebst hast du sie gekriegt
ich bin ein bisschen in der mitte rum
au au au jetzt hat es ein bisschen viel hier
oh ich wurde ich wurde gerüstet
gleich wieder da ich brauch fünf sekunden bin ich wieder am spot
die mercy steht richtung denen ihren spawn und die fahrer sind in der mitte drinnen
ok passt easy
die haben keinen bock nur auf tracer zu gehen sind so anstrengend
immerhin wir wollten nicht so mit oder merkt sich jetzt
mittlerweile lief als group das ist richtige verbesserung hat sich mal endlich was getan
seit sie ist ein eins
das ist gleich schon viel weniger tilt lastig aber zu zweit spiel
oder wir könnten ich ich warte mal ob einer schild noch schild pickt ich gehe mal nicht
von außen ich bleibe mal orissa orissa ist ja erster punkt nicht verkehrt zumal wir jetzt
ja immerhin den noscope 366 haben also der ist der macht nicht nur die 60s der macht
noch ein bit der macht noch sechs grad mehr
join voice please ach wir sind gar nicht im voice das ist gut für uns dass wir nicht
im voice ansonsten müssen wir uns den scheiß anhören
ich habe jetzt im neuen account letztens im stream leute was wie oft haben da leute geredet
es hielte sich in grenzen oder
ich glaube das liegt aber auch ein bisschen an eu weil in eu hast du halt gleich erstmal
acht verschiedene sprachen das problem hast du bei ein a weniger und in korea gar nicht
du kriegst ja immer mit wie die franzosen schon ins drum flame oder die russin dann
aber halt als auf russisch dass keiner versteht oder auf französisch
ich sterbe jungs
die haben schon gehört dass mein schild hält nicht lange es ist down schild ist da
kommen die von hinten um knapp knapp da hat nicht mehr viel oben da ist ziemlich lauter
junkrat so drunter zu ziehen so down jetzt muss ich sagen ein bisschen weniger fieden
der router macht action hinten stopt die gehen wir da vor stopt die gehen wir da vor
roter geht da ich brauche hier fahrt
von wo von wo von wo kommt der sprach hier sprach sorry auf den punkten ich habe bongos
oh wir haben den teleporter sehr sehr nice was extra bongos hingestellt bongo bongo
nicht hieling nicht hieling nicht hieling
das ich kann überhaupt nicht vorne hin
ich sage erst ultra law ding ding ding ding ding ding
rottach
oh fuck fuck fuck fuck fuck ich habe gleich wieder bongos ich bleibe jetzt noch ganz kurz
mal auf orissa hallo voracius
ich bongo gleich eine runde sobald die um die ecke kommen
die porsche aber nicht können jetzt eigentlich wir können eigentlich porschen aber da muss
halt muss halt wer mitgehen bongo
ist fast dauernd der rottach
soll das nicht so sehr auf extend
ich bin dran ich bin dran
fast dauerndisar ja vorne
da kommt keiner mit schmuck schanke das rechts ja
mit reinhardt plus orisa ist das neues tankmeter spiel plus on bastion
der reinhardt ist fast dort
ja die war ah ne die war schon weg äh solcher
mei mei perfekt ich weiß gar nicht wo die ist
aber das kann man gewinnen wird gehuckt
kannst du den manjarowort noch mal nicht hochladen ich habe den selbst nicht
also mit video maker muss ich mich echt mal wieder ein paar wochen hinsetzen ich habe
immer das gefühl ich drücke auf den knopf nach links klick und fünf jahre später kommt
erst mal der input dann ist keine ahnung voll komisch wahrscheinlich auch eine übungssache
ich finde ihn der input in overwatch ist eh gewöhnungsbedürftig also er fühlt sich
definitiv anders an wie jetzt sagen wir mal ein battlefield oder ein cs ich weiß nicht
genau woran das liegt das ist mit hohen fps nicht so sehr spürbar wie mit niedrigen aber
es ist anders einfach nur ich kann jetzt nicht sagen ob besser oder schlechter was ist anders
aber ich habe generell so ein bisschen problem mit dem fisch augen effekt bei 100 3 4 4 echt
schmeckt davon gar nix fällt dir das nicht auf wenn du in die ferne guckst und dann sagen
wir mal du guckst mal auf so ein spielautomaten hier stellt sich hierhin auf spielautomaten
und dann drehst du weg deine kameraden kommt immer näher an also fisch augen effekt ja
so ein ganz kleines bisschen ja gut ich meine es geht halt auch nicht anders weil theoretisch
kannst du ja 360 field of view machen da muss halt flasche fisch augen sein wisse aber es
geht mit 90 90 kannst du in dem game vergessen siehst du zu wenig sie ist nicht so wenig
aber die reichheit und alles das verkürzt sich das richtig am arsch an die optik stand
letztens erst vor der tracer links krieg gemacht mit reinheit das ist scheiße wir werden zugespammt
ich versuche klammer irgendwie hockerino und hab mich guckt die sau fack das gibt es
doch nicht sagt zwar außer range macht muss die falle kaputt machen ich hab den reinheit
was sie lebt noch
passt spetzung
So, wieder Full-Sworn-Ready.
Easy.
Tracer... Pass auf!
Tracer ist wirklich OP, weil man sie gut spielen kann auf Timing.
Das ist übertrieben.
Dich hat was gehockt?
Ja.
Drei hat dich gehockt.
Oh nee.
Das ist auch teuer, ne?
Ja.
Rechts ist Nordhock.
Und die Mercy.
Oh! Jetzt werde ich geholtet.
Und das Schild ist abgelaufen. Oh, das war Dorf.
Wir müssen mal regroupen.
Kommt her, Leute.
Die Leute, die ich gekillt habe, wurden alle wiedergerast.
Mercy balanced.
Ich fand die alte Mercy viel besser.
Das ist jetzt so richtig räudig einfach nur.
Jump gehockt?
Ja.
Oh, nice sleep, nice sleep, Ana.
Wo ist das Kacktire?
Nein, ich bin da.
Ich pushe mal ein bisschen.
In die Falle.
Oh nein, jetzt ist die Fahrer an Lars Stand vom Junkyard verrecknet.
Wie ist das denn?
Mehrtürdom, wo er nicht Granaten fallen lässt.
Das ist echt scheiße.
Leute, wo seid ihr denn?
So, weg.
Geht doch.
Dreimal Splitter, Munition, Mörttürdom, LMG, Ship mit 64-Mann-Cot.
Nein, wir wollen es ja mal nicht übertreiben.
Nein.
Fuck.
Ich pushe mal mit Paylord.
Pushes außer Saria keiner.
Also genau die falschen zwei hinten jetzt die pushen.
So pushen als gar nicht pushen.
Ich geh mal ein Stück zurück.
Ich kann grad nicht weiter vor.
Ich switche gleich auf Reinhard.
Frauenschild, ohne Schild geht das hier nicht.
Okay, jetzt haben wir ein paar Picks.
Jetzt aber alles umgefallen.
Hallo, Baby.
Ich geh mal ein bisschen vor.
Krall mir irgendwas, was da rauskommt.
Das ist natürlich der Roadhog.
Frau, heal, heal, heal.
Moment, wo sind die Leute?
An was sind wir denn jetzt?
Jetzt kommen die krassen Reinhard-Plays.
Genau Leute.
Ja, eigentlich wollten wir gar nicht streamen.
Da haben wir uns aber gedacht.
So geht es ja nicht.
Ich hör schon wieder was auf dem Micron.
Oh, die müssen mitkommen.
Schild bricht, Schild bricht.
Von hinten, Reinhard von hinten.
Reckt, weggehämmert.
Hörst du keine Musik beim Spielen?
Ich, eh doch, normalerweise schon leise.
Aber es ist mir grad zu viel.
Wenn wir quasi zu zweit schon im TS sind.
Plus hier In-Game-Sound und so, das ist zu viel.
Hör mal, wer der Hammered Kicks Edition.
Und was sollen wir mit Orisa probieren oder Reinhard?
Ich finde hier Orisa aber ziemlich gut.
Also es hat funktioniert.
Als die klassische Variante.
Ja, ich finde es.
Moins Nuberus.
Wie spricht man das richtig aus?
Du weißt ja, ich habe 100 Stunden Main-Tech-Erfahrung in dem Game.
Wo stellt man sich hier am besten hin?
Das kriege ich schon hin.
Gar so schlimm ist es nicht.
Ja, so schlimm ist es nicht.
Ich glaube die Mercy stirbt jetzt, weil sie denkt sie muss mit dir da rum hüpfen.
Komm zurück Leute.
Ich habe gar nicht den Pro Fire Strike gemacht am Anfang.
Den alle machen.
Oh, die haben Reaper.
Ich bin reingehuckt vorne.
Ich habe den Reaper.
Bam, schreckt.
Ich bin wieder reingehuckt.
Also nicht gehuckt, sondern ich komme in der D.Va vorgeflogen.
Sonst bin ich immer rechtzeitig da.
Das packen wir nicht.
Ich bleibe lieber auf dem Reinhard, dass ich einen Shatter bekomme.
Warum gehen wir da nochmal?
Können wir das echt noch gewinnen?
Ich habe so meine Zweifel.
Hätte ich früher rangehen müssen.
Ich bin noch drauf, das war jetzt viel zu spät.
Ich habe es nicht gecheckt, dass ihr mit Tele rankommen könnt.
Das ist nicht richtig blöd.
Ich habe mich schon vorbereitet auf den zweiten Punkt.
Habe ich gesehen am Moment, warum sind da auf einmal so viele Leute vorne?
Ich verrecke Leute.
Oh, Shatter gleich da, 3%.
Da gibt es Huge Shatter.
Big Slam.
Vom Dach aus.
Ich gehe jetzt aufs Dach und slam auf den Kopf von denen.
Jetzt geht es ab.
Huge.
Es hätte klappen können.
Das ist Übelstrap.
Ich komme als D.Va wieder.
Der letzte Loop.
Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, was ich da zocken soll.
Du bist so ein mega Gespenner.
Ich muss mein Auto wieder kriegen.
Ich habe mir bloß eine Sache gebraucht.
Wieder da.
Die drehen sich jetzt um.
Das gibt es nicht.
Es ist Hardcore.
Wir haben noch eine Chance zu gewinnen.
Ich habe alles auf Low, aber ich sehe nichts.
Wir haben auch einen Symmetra Main.
Der Toxic hat eine ganze Zeit Symmetra gespielt.
Ich glaube, da hat sogar Attack Symmetra gespielt.
Für Game mit Symmetra Main machen wir das eigentlich ganz gut.
WTF, was ist das?
Ich habe keine Mercy.
Mit sagenhaften...
Wie viele Stunden?
Null.
Jetzt geht es ab.
Auf dem Main Account ist es auch nicht mehr.
Ich muss unsere Leute heilen.
Ich heile dich.
Ich bin fast da und muss mich kurz verstecken.
Wieder da.
Ich bleibe bei unserer Fahrer.
Ich bleibe jetzt am Kart.
Wenn du brauchst, guck mal, dass ich zu dir fliegen kann.
Ich verstecke mich kurz.
Wo ist er denn?
Da war ich gerade, da ist er nicht.
Ich flieg mal rum, ich komme zu dir vor.
Du darfst nicht runtergehen.
Ich fliege, ich kann fliegen, easy.
Ach Moment, man hat gar keinen Rätsel.
Instant am Start, was ist das?
Ich habe so keine Ahnung von dem Held.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie die Mercy funktioniert.
Das ist jetzt absolut peinlich.
Schanker ist oben rechts.
Ich habe keine Rätsel.
Ich muss weg.
Ich komme so schnell, wie es geht.
Jetzt gibt es aufs Maul.
Leider konnte ich euch mit meinen Mercy-Plays nicht komplett carryen.
Es ging leider nicht.
Was ist so ein dummer Held?
Verloren habe ich 7 Punkte.
Das ist gar nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel es vorher war.
Es war auf jeden Fall nicht viel.
Über 25 bei dir.
Ja 25, RIP.
Ich bin nicht hoch genug im Ranking.
Ich habe 3x Held gewechselt.
Das ist ja auch schon ganz böse für das Ranking.
Außerdem habe ich Mercy auch noch richtig scheiße gespielt.
Der Witz ist da trotzdem gereicht.
Ich komme auf diese Spam-Scheiße.
Das ist nervig.
Ich glaube aktuell ist das Hauptproblem.
Es ist nicht so, wie es in den Chalk-Pointen gespammt wird.
Das kann auch jeder.
Das ist genauso schwierig, wie Mercy abzumachen.
Diese Kugel ist übertrieben.
Ich bin gespannt, bis einer eine gute Moira-Map findet.
Du hast es in einem Overwatch-League-Match gesehen.
Am nächsten Tag auf dieser Map alle Moira am Start.
Sie haben es auf Junkertown probiert.
Mit ganz merkwürdig.
Sombra, Moira und so weiter.
Man hat schon erkannt, was sie vorhatten.
In your face vom Gegner.
Aber es hat nichts gebracht.
Ich bin zerrissen.
Hallo Osterhase HD.
Ohne gute Map.
Nice.
Ich probiere es nochmal.
Ich rucke wieder ein bisschen.
Ich glaube, wir kriegen keinen Support.
Oder kriegen wir Support?
Ich bin gespannt.
Bist du im Voice-Chat?
Nein.
Ich auch nicht.
Das ist mir zu viel.
Das überfordert meine Denk-Synapsen.
Das ist zu viel auf einmal.
Moment.
Das Setup ist absoluter Scheiße.
Was ist das denn?
Es fehlt nur ein zweiter Heiler.
Komm, easy.
Ich...
Mercy!
Mercy plays wieder.
Ihr seht, ich habe keine andere Wahl.
Es ist nicht so, was ich will oder so.
Ihr könnt einfach Anna spielen.
Es macht doch eh nichts.
Aber Mercy ist zurzeit so OP.
No Mercy, no win.
Ja, der Rest ist halb.
Mal gucken, wohin es mit Widow geht.
Du musst einfach alles one-shotten.
Dann ist easy win.
Ich mache jetzt hier den...
Mindestens den Teimo machst du jetzt.
Mindestens.
Die sind alle über uns.
Das ist ziemlich kacke.
Hier ist ein Genji hinter uns.
Moment.
Wie macht man überhaupt Damage als Mercy?
Haha.
Hinter dir, Genji.
Huge.
Da sind ganz schön viele auf dir.
Da sind ganz schön viele auf dir drauf.
Ich muss hochfliegen zu dir.
Unsere Leute sollten mal...
Die sind alle auf mir.
Ich mache jetzt Damage.
Ich komme hoch.
Kannst du mich eventuell ressen?
Ich weiß nicht, wo du bist.
Hinten?
Ich habe Q gedrückt.
Du bist gerade echt gesagt, Widow stay on the payload?
Ja, hat er.
Das habe ich zumindest auch verstanden.
Ich sehe dich nicht.
Da konnte ich jetzt nichts machen.
Unsere Tracer macht den übels Flankerino.
Ich komme zu dir.
Wie machen das die Mercy eigentlich, dass die so ein Momentum kriegen?
Shift wieder loslassen und dann Leertaste drücken.
Ah.
Wie gut ich mich damit auskenne.
Komm jetzt, ich komme nicht zu dir hoch.
Vergiss es.
Kannst du knicken.
Ich sehe dich nicht.
Wenn man ein bisschen Damage boosts, kann man die Monitor den Rest zahlen.
Kommst du?
Wo bist du denn?
Hinten.
Ich muss den Reinhard heilen, der stirbt.
Nein.
Du hättest doch auf mir bleiben sollen.
Da wäre der Reinhard gestorben.
Ich weiß halt nicht, was ich machen muss.
Was heißt muss, ist eh schwierig so.
Ich habe wieder Old hier.
Huge Mercy Plays.
Kannst du mir ein bisschen Damage boosts oben?
Ja.
Wo machst du das?
Ich bleibe einfach mal mit Boost auf dir.
Mercy.
Das ist der wahre Mercy Skill hier, wie man sieht.
Eine Maustaste halten.
So, guck Leute, so kleibt man in ranked.
Eine Taste drücken.
Das war zu viel.
Ich hole dich, ich hole dich.
Jetzt bleibe ich auf dem Reinhard, mal drauf.
Moment.
Ja, ich bin hinter unseren DPS.
Ich habe null in Überblick gerade mit Mercy.
Ich geb dir Boost.
Kennen sie, kennen sie?
Nein, verfehlt.
Frank, ich komm zu dir hinter.
Seh dich schnell.
Hast du ihn?
Reinhard, guck doch nicht in diese Richtung.
It's Mercy, it's life.
Oh Gott.
Und ich hab gleich wieder Ulti.
Es ist eigentlich schlecht für ein SR, wenn man Heroes switcht.
Aktuell noch, ja.
Ich komm zu dir vor.
Aktuell noch, soll aber nicht mehr so sein lang.
Warum wussten wir da unbedingt jetzt durch, oder was?
Warum geht Mercy nicht runter?
ETF, kann Mercy aufhören zu fliegen?
Nein, geht nicht.
Flieg, Mercy, flieg, flieg.
Oh, ich hab ne Donation, ich guck die Donation danach.
Ich krieg so Anfälle, wenn ich Mercy spielen muss.
Das ist doch übelst chaotisch wieder alles.
Das ist schlimm, das ist echt schlimm.
Ich krieg anfälle, hier Mercy zu spielen.
Ja, Scarmaged, in Zukunft wollen sie das ändern.
Ich spiel in Defense keine Mercy mehr.
Kannst du auch damals dran erinnern, wo wir dann switchen wollten ein bisschen,
wo ich Mercy spielen sollte, wo ich mich immer davor gedrückt hab?
Verständlich.
Schrecklich, so.
Easy, keine Mercy mehr.
Egal, die sollen picken, was sie wollen, ich spiel keine Mercy mehr.
Instant 800 Viewer verloren, seit ich Mercy gespielt hab.
Jetzt sind's nur noch 70.
Oh, guck mal, wir haben zwei Heiler.
Es war keine Mercy, aber egal.
Wenn ich's jetzt tilten wollte, würde ich jetzt schreiben,
I have gold healing, what are you doing?
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Das sind immer die besten Typen, die anfangen,
You are useless, shit DPS, shit Tank, shit Support, I have gold.
Wobei da manchmal was dran ist, so ist es ja nicht.
Ja, tatsächlich.
So, ich muss in die Donation gucken.
Donation.
Donazione, was gibt's hier?
Leona Bomber 97, 5,40 Euro, Dankeschön,
Mit dem Geld kannst du dir den Zaun für die Katze kaufen.
Ich fürchte, also ich habe so die Vermutung,
Da könnten 5,40 Euro vielleicht nicht ganz reichen.
Aber wir werden's sehen.
Ja, Winston hat erstmal einen gefressen.
Sorry, Chat, keine huge Mercy plays diese Runde.
Die tucks.
Nee, oder? Alter, glaube ich nicht.
Die heilen mich nicht, die sind richtig afk, Mann.
Ich kann leider nichts dagegen machen.
So, ich muss runter.
Ich hab den Winston.
Und ich bin voll out of position jetzt, perfekt.
Wo seid ihr denn alle? Alter, wo seid ihr?
Ich krieg die Anfälle.
Du bist genauso gestorben wie ich. Keine Heilung bekommen, wahrscheinlich.
Naja, nee, ich war auch ziemlich am Arsch.
Also, Position. Ich hab versucht, dir den Winston wegzuhucken.
Das hat auch geklappt.
Und dann stand ich mit D.Va und Winston halt unten alleine.
Da haben sie mich geohnt.
Hast du eine neue Katze noch nicht?
Oh, das war kein Hook.
Komm her.
Hekt.
Ich bleibe am Kart, sonst pusht er.
Der hat kein Blade mehr.
Mach den Genji tot, er hat nur noch eins hinter uns.
Kein Bock. Wollen wir nicht.
Ich wäre schon längst tot, wenn ich jemals Heilen bekommen würde.
Das ist der Wahnsinn. Entweder das sind die Daimler und seine Scheiße oder...
Das regt mich gerade voll auf.
Das ist gar nichts.
Du bist einfach, du wirst voll geregt.
Aber hardcore geregt.
Ich geh hoch.
Moment, ich komm jetzt gleich an dir vorbei gelaufen.
Moment.
Können wir da mal drauf gehen vorne jetzt irgendwie Leute?
Geht das so? Ist das möglich?
Ja.
Was ist denn hier los?
Die können dann alle sterben permanent.
Ich hab das ganze Game noch nicht einmal Heilung bekommen.
Geht auch gerade gar nichts.
So, Winston.
Hekt.
Soldier oben links.
Sag mal, da fällt da alles um.
Nein, ich konnte nicht mehr kontaktieren.
Alter, was ist das denn?
Ich dachte, das sind die Suppots.
Moment, ja.
Alles gut, McCree ist glaube ich besser.
Kannst ein bisschen was, wenn ich es selbst mache.
Auch wieder sterben, weil ich keine Heilung kriege.
Du kannst ja immerhin mal kurz flashen, ja.
Alter, mach doch den Winston kaputt.
Es geht keiner mit auf die Gehockten.
Wo ist der Genji? Oben.
NA ult.
Nee, das war nicht NA, das war Überlebensult, weil ich wusste, was hinter mir abgeht.
Keine Heilung.
Hekt.
Ich muss mich verstecken.
Wie oft ich jetzt diesen verkackten Winston gebashed hab.
Ich konnte nichts machen.
NA ult, ja.
Das ist so schlimm.
Erst mal 5 Minuten Pause machen.
Ich explodiere gleich.
Wenn du keine Heilung bekommst, dann wundert es mich echt nicht, dass die Leute auf deinen Mund umkrebsen.
Du musst Soldier spielen, kannst selbst halt.
Bis gleich.
Ja, bis gleich.
Also Leute, ich hab den Winston 20 mal gekillt oder so.
Also das ist echt schwierig, ruhig zugeben.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Gab es einen Moment in deinem Leben, an dem du überlegt hast, professioneller Panflöten-Solist zu werden?
Das ist mir jetzt zu intim, diese Frage zu beantworten.
Da kann ich jetzt nichts zu sagen.
Und Winston hat immer noch überlebt.
Und alle hat er wieder gelebt.
Max, hast du mal Diablo gespielt und was hältst du davon?
Ich hab alle Diablo-Teile gespielt. 1, 2, 3.
1 war, finde ich, wegweisend.
2 war das beste Diablo, was es hier gegeben hat.
Und 3 war scheiße.
Ob es war so zu beschreiben, was ich von Diablo halte.
Das wäre Nummer 1. Geht gut, bloß die letzten zwei Games waren richtig kacke.
Das vierte Diablo fand ich am besten, ja, fand ich auch.
Nennt sich Pass of Exile, ist wirklich besser.
Also von allen Diablo-Style-Games, wenn man damit wirklich was spielen will,
so im Geiste von Diablo 2 früher Pass of Exile.
Das ist das beste Action-RPG, also Loot-zentrierte Action-RPG,
was es zur Zeit gibt und was es seit langer Zeit gegeben hat.
Was es schon eine Weile gibt, was super Content hat, was immer weiter ausgebaut wird.
Und als letztes irgendwas raus.
Findest du, dass Mercy immer noch ein Pflicht-Pick ist?
Eine der Gründe, warum wir eben verloren haben.
Zwei Gründe, warum wir eben verloren haben.
Erster Grund, weil ich Mercy spielen musste.
Zweiter Grund, weil wir danach, nachdem ich Mercy nicht mehr gespielt habe,
keine Mercy bekommen haben.
Irgendwie so eine komische Mischung aus Ana und Meurer.
Max würdest du sagen, i5 8600k auf 4,8 ist gut, mit maximal 82 Grad ist gut.
Ohne D-Lit, ja. Ohne D-Lit ist das gut.
4,8 unter, mit was, also 4,8 unter 82 Grad, mit was testest du das?
Also wenn du es irgendwie mit Prime testest oder so, ist das easy, ist das richtig gut.
Also ich hab, ich kann es euch jetzt ja mal zeigen.
Ich starte mal diese Intel Performance-Dinger.
Mal gucken, ob ich das einblenden kann.
Moment.
Was ist das jetzt am besten?
Äh, Fenster Capture machen, Moment, Fenster Capture.
Window Capture, da ist es.
Okay, die Dinger, die Dinger kann man nicht Capture.
Warum kann man das nicht Capture, hä?
Wartet mal, warte mal, das haben wir gleich. Game Capture.
Okay, die Dinger kann, man kann diese Intel Sachen nicht Capture.
Verstehe auch nicht, ich mach jetzt einfach, wir machen jetzt einfach komplett Monitor Capture.
Ich muss eh kurz warten, bis E-AX wieder da ist.
Hier, da sieht man es, guckt, aktuell läuft er auf 4,8, der taktet sich hoch bis auf 4,9.
Er ist gerade der Meinung, er braucht nicht mehr.
Er encoded bloß den Livestream, da muss man nicht hoch takten auf 4,9.
Das ist ja, nee, nee, nee, brauchen wir nicht.
Also meiner läuft auf mit 4,9 und ja, dann auch so in dem Dreh wie deiner, so 80, Pan 80.
Allerdings mit D-Lit und ordentlich V-Core hochgeschraubt.
Also man muss sagen, mit 6 Kern normalerweise ist 4,3 Gigahertz, ja.
18 Lootboxen, da müssen wir jetzt mal ran.
Wenn ein Gartenvideo in den Top 5 Trends kommt, das glaube ich nicht.
Dass es in die Top 5 Trends kommt.
Ich habe eh noch einige Cross Promotion slash Dual Commentary Videos geplant für diesen Monat.
Da haben wir auch schon ein paar Leute zugesagt.
Da haben wir alles dabei, der Fantu ist dabei, der Danny ist mal wieder dabei, Hardware Rat ist dabei.
Ich habe 10, 12 Leute mittlerweile, die nicht was machen will, die auch schon gesagt haben, jo auf gehts.
Baby, sag wenn du ready bist, ich mache Lootboxen auf.
Ganz kaum machen.
Okay.
Oh, jetzt wird geohnt.
Ist wirklich schwer, das wird man gar nicht vorausgehen auf Diamond.
Es zehrt auch an den Nerven.
Man kann wirklich sagen, du baust einen Healer und einen DPS, sonst kommst du da nicht weg.
Ich würde ja Anna spielen.
Das Problem ist eigentlich, du spielst jetzt irgendwie so eine Mischung aus.
Du spielst jetzt Mercy und als DPS vielleicht Tracer, wo du die Gegner outplayen kannst.
Aber ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich Mercy spielen muss.
Mir macht das Spiel wirklich sowas von, kein Spaß, wenn ich Mercy spielen muss.
Es ist wirklich Folter, Mercy spielen.
Mag den Helden auch nicht.
Also ich spiele wirklich nur noch dann, wenn ich...
Wenn es unbedingt sein muss, genau.
Gute Map.
Endlich.
Hanzo Therapy ist bei uns.
Was der wohl spielen wird?
Rate mal, was könnte das sein?
Warum stehen die eigentlich...
Moment, wir gucken uns den Typ jetzt mal an.
Widowmaker, 28 Stunden.
Hanzo, 23 Stunden.
Gefolgt von Junklet, 9 Stunden.
188 Games lost, 208 Games won.
Das könnte man...
Kann man nicht mal Hanzo Main nennen, oder?
Es ist...
Es ist Hybrid Main, so.
Also Hanzo Widow Hybrid Main.
Also quasi...
Quasi Winsow ist das.
Winsow Main.
Wenn du mir vorhin Damage Boost gegeben hast, für die 5 Sekunden, da ging es voller.
Ich hätte eigentlich stumpf auf dir bleiben müssen mit Damage Boost.
Das wäre das Beste gewesen, was gegangen wäre.
Hätten wir sie alle verrecken lassen können, aber du hättest sie alle mit Damage Boost gekillt.
Genau.
Das ist jetzt ohne Scheiß, das wäre wahrscheinlich wirklich das Beste gewesen, ne?
Also in der Defense habe ich keine Heimung bekommen, nicht einmal.
So wie in der...
Okay, wir haben ne Mercy. Wir haben zwar ne Moira, das ist aber okay. Ich meine für dich nicht.
Dich wird die Moira nicht heilen.
Junklet Spam? Kein Junklet Spam.
Achtung, jetzt kommt...
Jetzt wird gecarried.
Carry Hook.
Achtung, komm her Tracer, Tracer, Tracer, Tracer, Tracer.
Go, go, go.
Tracer hinter mir.
Wie hab ich denn das verhooked, ey? Gibt's doch nicht.
Tracer, piss dich, Alter, piss dich.
Mach Schild runter.
Oh, meine Hooks.
Die haben auch schon mal besser gesessen. Vor allem mit 1.0 Damage.
Mit 1.0 Damage gehen die Hooks ab. Da war Hook und direkt Down.
Das war geil damals, Roadhog. Ich meine, das war OP wie Sau, ne? Wenn man mal ehrlich ist.
Aber es war schon geil.
Ja, schon.
Tracer kommt von rechts.
Ich bin noch nicht nahe genug dran.
Was? Warum hat das nicht getroffen?
Ein A-Hook.
Richtig ein A-Hook.
Nichts getroffen.
Tracer?
Kack, Tracer. Tracer ist rechts irgendwo.
Jetzt aber. Ausgetracert.
Jetzt sitzen die Hooks.
Hast du vor, noch mal einen Hook zu treffen? Nee. 30% Accuracy Hook, easy.
Was ist hier los?
Muss die wichtigsten Hooks treffen.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch. Easy. Easy clap.
Ich habe immerhin 31% Hook Accuracy.
Wie die Pros.
Warum spiele ich eigentlich einen Helden, mit dem ich Übelstry haben muss?
Vielleicht brauchst du das.
Für welchen Helden war deine erste goldene Waffe auf dem Main, Lucio?
Ach komm, der Richie ist im Chat.
Und, spielst du noch Overwatch oder ist vorbei?
Der Rich im 1.
Ich sollte eigentlich auch eine Medaille haben.
Das spricht nicht gerade für meine überkrasse Roadhog Performance.
Aber jetzt kommt sie, jetzt geht es ab.
Moment, eben hatten wir noch ein Schild, da ist es.
Hoffentlich habe ich Freiraum zum Snipern.
So, jetzt wird die Hook Accuracy steigern.
Doch, wieder Tracer.
Reinhard, übertreib es mal nicht.
Oh, der war eigentlich drauf.
Ich mache das Schild kaputt.
Hörst du irgendwas hinter uns?
Nein, oder?
Das sind 4, doch ein Reinhard.
Jetzt auch ein Velo?
Ja.
Oh, oh, Reinhard.
Das war es.
Sobald ich eine Weile nicht gespielt habe, merke ich das richtig, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich machen soll.
Ich gucke da links, rechts, links, rechts, ich check null, wo es jetzt drauf ankommt.
Oh, Schnipsart.
Oh, die hat aber ein Glück.
Ich habe irgendwie ein Mikro, ich habe keine Ahnung warum.
Immer wenn ich links klicke, dann hängt das Spiel kurz.
Beim links klicken?
Ich frage mich gerade, was links klicken für krasse Performance Spikes verursachen kann.
Oh, die Tracer, die geht mir so auf die Sache, die kommt hoch zu dir hinter dir.
Ich habe noch keinen Hook.
Ich kriege die Krise, ich treffe diese verfickte scheiß Tracer nicht im Hook.
Alter, das war doch schon wieder drauf.
Ich treffe heute echt keinen Hook, aber nicht.
Chat sagt, du sollst Hanzo spielen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist.
Jetzt aber holt ihr auch mal Zeit.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ist der Reinhardt wieder da?
Nee, da kommt er.
Was? Wie hat der noch gehooked?
Du bist wirklich Hanzo?
Oh, Reinhardt, das war keine so gute Idee.
Ja, mein Climb ist verbackt. Danke, Blizzart. Danke.
Was ist?
Backt wirklich bei jedem links klicken oder was?
Das ist aber ganz schön räudig.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich die Hooks nicht treffe.
Ich glaube es nicht. Wie kann er immer trotzdem gehooked noch slammen?
Ich habe keine Damage Medaille, ich fühle mich schlecht.
Der Junkrat ging ab am Ende.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das schon wieder von der Kurze ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das noch ist, das ist echt anstrengend.
Ich kann mich wenigstens wieder in das Game reinfinden, was ja eigentlich der Zweck dieser ganzen Geschichte war.
Stell dir mal vor, ich hätte Main Account gespielt.
Ich hätte Main Account gespielt und hätte dann erst mal 30 Matches ungewollt throwen müssen, dass ich irgendwo wieder mitspielen könnte.
Das ist ja auch, das siehst du mal wie beknackt, das ist, dass jemand, der seit Season 3 nicht gespielt hat, internes Matchmaking immer noch Master GM gerankt wird.
Warum? Warum? Das ist einfach total, als bist du instant auf dem Niveau von damals, wenn du einfach ein halbes Jahr nicht gespielt hast.
Das ist Blizzart Logik.
Also mir reicht es schon eine Woche, um auf dem Niveau zu spielen, wie Diamant.
Wenn du eine Woche nicht zockst, das kannst du voll vergessen. Eine Woche ohne Overwatch.
Das ist wirklich, ich merke das auch, das ist wirklich schwierig. Ich könnte spüren teilweise, ja.
Hook ist drauf, drückste und dann ist der zwei Millimeter vorbei.
Und dann denkst du dir mal, ey, das kannst doch nicht sein.
Ich frage mich, wenn ihr eigentlich mal den Buck fixen wollt, mit diesem Hanzo Jump und Genji Jump da.
Wenn du springst und an eine Wand kletterst, hört einfach auf.
Echt? Kennst du diesen Winston Boost Jump?
Das finde ich auch geil. Das ist noch, glaube ich, seit einer Woche oder so, wo ich das mal irgendwo gesehen habe, wusste ich gar nicht, dass das ein Ding ist.
Oh, 2CP, jawoll.
Ab geht's.
Oh nein, wie das in einer Anna-Molra-Kombi.
Komm, scheiß drauf spielen, als Lothar kann ich mich selbst heilen.
Und außerdem kann ich meine Hook-Accuracy mal wieder ein bisschen in normale Regionen treiben.
Ist dir immer aufgefallen, was für eine dumme Musik diese Automaten hier machen.
Magst du Molra nicht oder wie?
Ich hab nichts gegen Molra.
Ich seh bloß Molra skeptisch als Heiler, wenn du halt diveen willst.
So ein bisschen zumindest hier mit Winston und naja, vielleicht ein bisschen Sombra.
Du kannst da mit Molra nichts heilen gescheit.
Außer du stehst halt hinter einem Reinhardt oder so was.
Also das ist schwierig mit Molra.
Das hast du ja auch gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du Blackfyre 21, ich weiß nicht, ob du Overwatch League geguckt hast.
Da hat's Dallas ja probiert.
Auf Junkertown, das sind halt auch sang- und klanglos untergegangen.
Obwohl die schon eingespielt sind und Hellen-Kombi hatten, die zugepasst hat.
Rekt.
Mercy hinterm Tor.
Mercy weg.
Sniper oben links.
Wat, warum sterben grad alle?
Ich hab also dezent gar nichts gemacht.
Macht nix, macht nix.
Wir haben Golddamage, jetzt geht's ab hier, Leute.
Ich sag's euch.
Jetzt geht's ab mit Roadhog.
Was hat die Mercy da gemacht?
Gute Frage.
Gut, sehr gute Frage.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Sie ist hinterm Tor versteckt, weil sie gedacht hat, das ist ne gute Vorsicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Jawoll.
Jetzt geht's rein hier.
Direkt rein.
Frontal.
Ich hab gleich nochmal gesnipst.
Danke, Mercy.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Ich bin fast down.
Hallo, warum nehmen wir nicht ein?
Mercy, Mercy, Mercy.
Fuh.
Hallo, einnehmen.
Das ist doch schlimm.
Ey, es will keiner drauf, oder was?
Huge Plays, ja, Huge Plays.
Oh, das war ein Hit.
Aber kein Hit schon.
Das ist cool, dass die 40, das geht aufwärts.
Keine Headshots, keine Headshots.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Bitte hilf.
Na, super.
Debated.
Roadhog ist einfach zu fett.
Da werden sie geschniped.
Jawoll, Backcap.
Was macht die Mercy denn da?
Also ihre Mercy ist down.
Es geht halt auf den Spot.
Geht auf den Spot, Leute, ist doch keiner.
Jawoll, weggeblasen, so muss es sein.
Weggeblasen.
Wie willst du es sonst nennen?
Huge Plays, bitte hier, Huge Plays.
Ich guck mal, ob einer Schild pickt.
Wenn keiner Schild pickt, dann mach ich das.
Hier ist Urissa richtig gut.
Moment, was ist denn, was zum Teufel ist...
Das Sombra in der Defense, du hast doch gar kein gutes Medpack.
Was gibt denn das jetzt hier, wenn es fertig ist?
Wir haben kein Schild.
Wir können doch nicht mit Zen als Single Support Defense spielen.
Also ich bin geneigt jetzt entweder eine Mercy oder eine Ana zu nehmen noch.
Aber da haben wir gar kein Schild, außer Winston.
Und Winston an diesem Chalk ist für'n Arsch.
Was sind hier lieber, noch ein Support oder ein Schild?
Überhaupt mal ein Support, das war nice.
Scheiß drauf.
Ich nehm jetzt wenigstens einen Support, der mir Spaß macht.
Die Defense, bloß wenn es ein Healing Order ist.
Wahnsinn.
Ja, dreimal darfst du raten.
Ja Leute, dann pickt halt ein Support, wir wollen das doch nicht mit Zen als Solo Defense spielen hier.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Die ist halt auch so, du Witz.
Aufpassen auf Widow.
Okay, sag mal wo die ist, ob ich rausgucken kann hinten.
Kann ich dir nicht sagen, ich sehe sie hier nicht.
Ja, die ist auf mir drauf schon.
Und so haben sie auch noch.
Man spielt hier glaube ich am besten einfach was man will.
Jetzt glaubt es, vergisst es einfach.
Boah, das war ein dicker Hatch.
WTF.
Ich hab nur noch, ja noch, ich hab wieder genug Leben.
Oh, das war ein schöner Hack.
Ich brauch den.
Ich die ganze Zeit Mikro, ich versteh das nicht.
Sag, wenn du Heal brauchst, du bist oben hier auf dem Geländer.
Ja Sombra, da kann ich dir nicht helfen.
Hanzo hat es auf mich abgesehen.
Sleept.
Huge Plays.
Oh oh, ich bin im Craft mit drin.
Eigentlich unverständlich, dass wir das verloren haben.
Das war eigentlich richtig gut.
Aber noch haben wir es ja nicht verloren.
Ne, den Fight hier am Tor.
Das war eigentlich richtig gut.
Jetzt haben sie es schon drauf gesehen.
Roman brauchst du Heal?
Du hast Zen drauf, pass.
Tracer, Tracer.
Ich hab ne Tracer gehört.
Oh, wie knapp.
Ich hab Roadhog Schüsse abgekriegt.
Ist nicht so genau von wo.
Oben links, oben links ist ein Roadhog.
Brauchst du Hilfe?
Ich treff links gerade.
Was machen die Gegner eigentlich da?
Ich hab wieder Nano Bus.
Da ist noch was drinne.
Da ist noch was drinne, auf jeden Fall.
Ich hab irgendwas gehört, noch links im Gebäude.
Tracer.
Ja Sombra, aufe Extender halt einfach wie der letzte.
Nein, ich hab gesleept und bin selbst noch verreckt.
Bitter, aber okay.
Okay, easy.
Das war halt mal mega C9.
Hardcore C9.
Ana macht so Bock.
Die sollen Ana wieder gut patchen oder Mercy einfach useless machen, dass man wieder Ana spielen kann.
So, Season 3 Zeit, oder?
Das ist nicht passiert.
Ein Stock kurz gepiekt, Sleep Dart.
Bam, hat er gelegen.
Jetzt hat er zwar gelegen, aber ich hab auch gelegen.
Vielleicht haben die Gegner einfach keine Lust zu pushen.
Wir müssten eigentlich mal so Post-Match-Interview machen.
Was war los?
Wie haben sie das Spiel empfunden?
Herr, wen haben wir hier, Reset Player?
Schaffer und Altsk.
Oder OG9.
Das ist ein Widow-Main, der hat schon Widow-Eigen.
Nee, Roadhog-Main, das ist es.
Lootbox.
Easy Lucio Goldskin.
Nein.
Ich war letztens bei Tivik im Stream und da hat er Anubis gespielt.
Oh nee, was gibt denn das wieder?
Da hat er Anubis gespielt.
Ich hab halt ein bisschen über den Game Mode abgeflammt.
Und da meint er so, er finde, das ist der beste Spiel-Modus.
Und dann extra noch mal hinterher gesagt, dass er das wirklich ernst meint.
Also es findet nicht jeder 2CP-Scheiße.
Wer hat das gesagt?
Tivik.
Ich war letztens bei ihm im Stream, hab rumgeflammt.
Wie spricht Tivik aus?
Tivik, den spricht man so aus.
Was?
Wie sprichst du ihn denn aus?
Twig?
Twig.
Nein, ich glaub, den spricht Tivik aus.
Twig, hey.
Twig.
Früher hat er sich Tivik geschrieben.
Jetzt spricht mir der nur noch T-V-I-Q.
900 IQ.
Zumindest findet er 2CP-Bester-Modus.
Bin ich so ein bisschen vom Glauben abgefallen, als ich das gehört hab.
Und er hat extra noch mal gesagt, er meint es ernst.
Ich glaub, das ist ein talk-about-Witz gewesen.
Nein, nein.
Der hat, das glaub ich nicht.
Er hat extra danach, so 10 Sekunden später, weil er hat es so trocken gesagt, so Null-Best-Mode,
so irgendwie in der Richtung.
Dann hab ich schon gedacht, ja klar, du findest ihn auch scheiße.
Danach hat er noch mal gemeint hier, das ist jetzt hier weder kappa noch ironic oder sonst
was.
Er meint das wirklich so.
Das kann ich nicht glauben.
Ich auch nicht, aber er hat's gesagt.
Ich suche mir neun Favoriten.
Wär's gestorben, ich will neun Lieblingsnamen.
Time of Inner 2 CP auch scheiße.
Maywall.
Wer kommt hier rein?
Ah, ich bin hinter dir.
Nein, Mei links bei mir, hilf mir, ich bin gleich da und der Router ist low, super low.
Ich will hierdurch.
Mei 1 HP.
Ich bin am Punkt.
Ja, jetzt nicht.
Geil.
Vielleicht hat er eine schwere Kopfverletzung erlitten, schreibt er im Chat.
Wirklich, wirklich.
Einen Tag vorher wurden sie ja hart gerapt von Dallas Fuel vielleicht.
Und ich glaube 2 CP haben sie sogar auch verloren.
Keine Ahnung.
Spam.
Schreckt McCree, schreckt.
Jawoll, go go.
Merci, jawoll, huge plays, chat, huge plays.
Kommt jetzt noch die Beaver, der Monkey.
Huge, Lucio ist noch am Start.
Die Hooks sitzen, oh fuck, fuck, fuck, fast down gewesen.
Was?
Ey, das gibt's nicht.
WTF?
Ich hasse es.
Wahnsinn.
2 CP, LOL.
Oh, der Genji, huge, huge Genji plays.
Huge plays, huge plays.
Yeah.
Oh, Gott sei Dank.
Hooker Cruiser 71, diesmal geht's ab.
Kann das sein, dass der Champ ein bisschen OP ist?
Roadhog, nee, ich glaube, nee.
Ich finde, Roadhog ist zum ersten Mal jetzt so richtig balanced.
Ja, nein, nein, eigentlich nicht.
Eigentlich ist er zum ersten Mal richtig balanced.
Ich meine, das war schon scheiß OP.
Komm mal, du hast, du hast quasi mit dem richtigen, kennst du noch diese seitlich Pull, dieser
seitlich Pull Trick, den du früher machen konntest, wo du sie dir direkt.
Kannst du doch jetzt immer noch.
Weiß ich, keine Ahnung, ob das mit Hook 2-0 immer noch geht.
Aber da kannst du sogar, wenn du gut warst, einen Zarya One Shot.
Und das war schon ein bisschen übertrieben, oder?
So minimal.
Ja gut, damals war der Hook ein bisschen zu nahe herangezogen, aber jetzt hast du halt.
Hey, jetzt stirbt halt nichts mehr.
Ja, das ist schon ein Problem, das stimmt.
Du hast damals schon richtig krass Ultimates gefiedelt, indem du einfach nur da geschüttelt
hast und dann hast du 10 Kilometer gebrochen.
Soll ich, soll ich Schild nehmen?
Ja, ich nehme Schild, ha?
Zetzen gern, Urissa oder Reinhardt?
Reinhardt, etwas vieles.
Kannst schon ein bisschen Tank üben, er hat verkehrt.
Aber ich fand das damals schon richtig so, dass du einen Counter gebraucht hast.
Entweder hast du halt, keine Ahnung, Zarya mit dem Punkt des Shields gezockt.
Gegen Hook.
Ja.
Ich fand, das war auch ganz, ganz, ganz clever.
Ich meine, da hast du gemerkt, das war halt von Anfang an so gedacht, weißt du?
Mit den Zarya Schilden als Hook-Counter.
Das fand ich damals auch so richtig in Ordnung, das hat auch mega Spaß gemacht.
Du hast halt nicht die richtigen Picks genommen.
Du hast halt das Ganze mit verloren.
Ja, du konntest richtig geile Plays machen mit Zarya damals.
Also gerade durch sowas.
Pass auf, wer ist da vorne?
Wer stirbt als erstes?
Moira wird gesniped.
Moira wird gesniped, nein wird's nicht.
Okay.
Ich glaube, die gehen rechts durch.
Mercy ist ziemlich low, linke Seite.
Fuck, ich wollte gerade weg.
Scheiße.
Ich hab mich umgecharged.
Ich wollte gerade zurückchargen.
Gerätzt, nice du, nice und nice du.
Your face.
Oh Gott.
Moin, Chestos.
Ich geh mal wieder vor Richtung Chalkpoint.
McCree steht schon da rum.
Ich brauch Heal.
Oh, diese Moira Kugel, ey.
Die hat gerade keine DPS genommen.
Ich hab Reaper auf mir drauf.
Huge Plays.
Oh ne.
Ich bleib gerade nicht durch.
Fuck, ich wurd gestunt.
Ein bisschen Übung werd ich noch rein hat, Main.
Wieso gehen die Kugeln durch?
Die flanken links rum.
Ey, das ist so schlimm.
Es passiert einfach nix.
Ich switch jetzt.
Ist drauf.
Ist auf jeden Fall noch rechtzeitig zum Punkt zurückgekommen.
Ah, rekt.
Ich bleib mal Soldier und stell mich Chalkpoint hin.
Mir fehlt als Reinhardt gefühlt ein wenig der Support.
Patrick, was ist denn frustrierend, was meinste?
Oder meinste allein schon das Zugucken ist frustrierend?
Die lassen sich übrigens da hinten gerade übelst abfarben.
Fuck, fuck.
Ich renn noch ein bisschen auf den Spot rum.
Huge Plays, huge Plays, huge Plays.
Oh ey, alles musst du selbst machen.
Ja Patrick, das Rätsel von Mercy ist gerade eines der Spaßkiller an dem Game schlechthin.
Auch fürs Zuschauen ist das übelst verwirrend.
Leute, lasst euch bitte vorne nicht abfarben.
Ich komm ja ausgegrenzt vor hier hinten.
Ich steh hier mit Soldier rum und es kommt nix.
So, geh jetzt vor.
Nein, das geht so nicht.
Ich wollt grad Granatboost machen.
Die stehen mir halt alle vor der Flinte rum.
Ich bleib hinten stehen, easy.
Geh mal rechts rum.
Oh, jetzt kommt was.
Ich hab Visor.
Super, ist rechts noch gewesen.
Ich glaub wir sollten einfach eben doppel DPS spielen, gut, easy.
Okay, Max, nicht hier hinten drauf.
Das ist einfach zu defensiv.
Wir wollen vorne am Choke stehen.
Ich fahr mal ne Runde, okay?
Ich seh grad den Headshot gemacht, doch der Stank wird ersticht und der Damage kann nie an.
Oh, wie knapp.
Bisschen overextended.
Ganz kleines bisschen.
Ups.
Ich bin auf der Mercy drauf.
Ich treff sie aber nicht.
Wie, Mercy, wer hat sich diesen Held ausgedacht?
Alter!
Das macht mich fertig.
Okay, Reinhard, zack.
Komm, das halten wir als first point.
Easy.
Wer ist jetzt nerviger, die alte oder die neue Mercy?
Die neue.
Die neue Mercy.
Die alte Mercy war auf sonderbare Art und Weise irgendwie balanced.
Sonderbar halt, weil sie quasi das Nichtspielen belohnt hat.
Das war schon irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Aber der Rätts war okay, du wusstest, hey, Mercy hat jetzt ungefähr so und so lang Zeit gehabt, konnte so und so viel heilen, hat jetzt bestimmt Rätts am Start.
Das heißt, du hast auch schön geguckt, wenn du Leute gekillt hast, von wo kommt die Mercy vielleicht reingeflogen oder was ist.
Das geht, oder Fahrer mit Mercy und so, das war in Ordnung.
Aber jetzt, ich mein, hallo, was ist das für ne Scheiße? Du kannst ja quasi nicht mehr ohne Mercy spielen.
Von uns?
Ja, sehr geil.
Jetzt er moved sich, er moved sich.
Bewegt sich.
Am besten ist das noch, nee, zum Glück nicht, glaube ich.
Ich muss ein Stückchen zurück.
Reaper, Reaper, Reaper, ich geh auf den Point.
Wir sind gegeneinander gecharged.
Ich hab gleich Shatter.
Nice.
So muss das sein.
Yeah, good job.
Wir bleiben erstmal duo.
Du siehst meinen aktuellen Rank seit Season 3, wir können da gerne mal zusammenspielen.
Welchem Rang bist du gerade?
Ok, Reno.
Guck mal, guck mal, wie viel Zeit wir haben.
Also, wenn wir das nicht schaffen, dann uninstall ich.
Weil ich soll das vielleicht nicht so laut sagen, oder?
Nee, nicht so laut, das darfst du uns für nicht sagen.
Gibt so einen Ready-Post, 10.000 Uploads und dann bist du erst mal eine Woche weg.
Echt gebannt.
Das ist bestimmt auch gegen Blizzard Guidelines, im Zweifel ist alles irgendwie gegen Blizzard Guidelines.
Vorspielung falscher Tatsachen im Stream, gleich Twitch spannen, Overwatch spannen, Anzeige.
Alles.
Da kommen die ersten Leute, schade, ich hab's geklippt.
Nee, Richie, ich bin auch 3,1, ich bin auch schlecht, ich hab's aus diesen 3 nochmal gespielt, das passt schon.
War auch wieder am lernen.
Ist hier irgendwo eine Tracer am Start?
Ja, oben oben oben, und ich brauch Heilung.
Tracer ist natürlich behindert.
Nice.
Ich mach das Schild kaputt.
Schild kaputt.
Junkrat, nächster Hook, ein bisschen.
Orissa.
Mach den Junk da weg, mach ihn weg.
Nein, nein, nein, ich kann nicht, ich hab die Orissa gehuckt.
Oh, wir weg.
Ich bin auf den Punkt gleich.
Junk, Junk ist down.
Schon wieder Tracer auf mir.
McCree, rekt.
Jetzt sitzen die Hooks, jetzt fliegt's hier.
Oh oh, Junkrat.
Wo ist die Tracer?
Da war die Tracer.
Warte mal, bevor du uns rausziehst, vielleicht plotte ich auf die Camp.
Jetzt, jetzt bin ich wahnsinnig scared, fliegen die Hooks hier.
Pushe Gengur.
Gongo.
Oh guck mal, ich hab Shift gedrückt.
Huge Play, Shift, Huge Shift Play.
Das gab ein bisschen was, ne?
Ja.
40?
31.
Das speichere ich mir mal, da kann man den ein oder anderen guten Moment verwursten für ein Video.
Oh, warte mal.
Oh fuck, ja.
Ich hab gecancelt.
Geh mal einen anderen Nvidia Trepper installieren, vielleicht liegt's da.
Macht das mal, ich geh mal pinkeln.
Stream, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich mach euch ein bisschen Musik an.
Was machen wir an?
Rammstein.
Bam.
Oh, dann Instant Pan.
Ich guck jetzt mal eine Playlist durch, was da schönes drin ist.
Ja, das muss sein.
Ich bin mal kurz am Klo.
Da bin ich.
Ja.
So, wieder am Start.
Ich bin wieder da.
Der Ers schreibt grad, er installiert Nvidia Trepper, ist demnächst wieder am Start.
Noch zwei Minuten und geht's weiter.
Ja, willschi, ich edit dich mal.
Watt, mach ich gleich hier, wenn wir on.
Du sind's.
Add Friend.
Zack.
Sieh, ist raus.
So Leute, wenns hier irgendwelche Fragen gibt, schieß los.
Also eh noch mal warten, bis der Ers wieder da ist.
Können wir das jetzt auch kurz in der Runde FAQ machen.
Oder auch genannt, fuck.
Die Aussprache, fuck, find ich...
Wer sagt schon FAQ?
Und noch, fuck.
So, genug Schwachsinn erzählt.
Kann ein bisschen, was könnte man mal im Hintergrund machen?
Was könnte man da mal im Hintergrund anmachen?
Most epic powerful battle music.
Most epic aggressive modern...
Ach du sch...
Was ist das für ein Titel?
Pass mal auf.
Most epic aggressive modern hybrid orchestral music.
Most epic aggressive modern hybrid orchestral mus...
Ach du scheiß, das müssen wir uns jetzt mal anhören.
Okay, hör zu, schau mal aggressiv an.
Richtig aggressiv.
Das ist irgendwie Dead Space.
Ist das Dead Space?
Nee, ist kein Dead Space.
Hat schon ein bisschen angehört mit Dead Space.
So.
Kommt im nächsten noch mal eine Fortsetzung von dem Auswander mit meiner Freundin Video.
Du meinst ja, du hast ein Buch mit lauter Sonnenfragen.
Ja, mach ich, mach ich.
Jetzt muss ich aber erstmal meine ganzen Dual-Videos an Start kriegen.
Bisschen, bisschen Cross-Promotion betreiben.
Das ist auch wichtig für den YouTube-Algorithmus, weil aktuell ist es so,
ich kriege pro Upload mehr De-Abos als Abos.
Also so, als würde YouTube...
Also würden alle, die feststellen, ihnen gefällt das nicht mehr,
De-Abonnieren plus YouTube auch alle inaktiven Konten quasi nochmal aufräumen bei einem Upload.
Also es ist bisschen demotivierend auch, gerade überhaupt was hochzuladen.
Deswegen muss ich erstmal meine ganze Cross-Promotion-Geschichte jetzt mal raushauen.
Dass das wieder geht.
Weil ich mein, irgendwann will ich auch mal 300k haben.
Okay, also das ist jetzt Most Epic Aggressive Hybrid Orchestral Music.
Aber was anderes an.
Spoilerst du mit wem?
Ja, hab ich, ich hab vorhin schon ein paar gesagt.
Ich hab jetzt leider die Liste nicht da, die hab ich auf meinem anderen Account.
Also wer ist denn dabei?
Der Fanto ist dabei, Hardwarerad ist dabei, der Danny ist mal wieder dabei.
Eine Redakteurin von Deserto.
Der macht was zur Overwatch League.
Ist doch alles dabei, sind total viele.
Ich komm jetzt total bescheuert.
Den Mesh hab ich noch nicht gefragt, aber der ist bestimmt auch mit dabei.
Der Solution, der weiß von seinem Glück aber noch nix.
Aber noch alles.
Wir haben von einigen auch schon Rückmeldungen.
Also alle, die ich gefragt hab, sind auch mit dabei.
Dann versuch ich noch mit ein paar Overwatch-Kanälen was zu machen.
Gibt's da gerade viel Overwatch-Content, den man besprechen kann.
Einige.
Hättest du gedacht, dass X2Z sich in der Preseason so gut schlägt?
Besonders Nobani gegen Florida war ja richtig stark.
Und muss zugeben, dass er ein bisschen überrascht war.
Ja, hätt ich.
Also, dass er so gut ist, ist immer so ein bisschen variabel.
Es gibt auch Leute, die enttäuschen einen.
Da denkst du, da geht voll ab und geht nicht.
Aber was hätt ich erwartet?
Erstens, wenn man sich anguckt, spielt er am Endeffekt Orisa, Reinhardt und Winston.
Das sind ja eigentlich so seine drei Haupthelden.
Und wenn man sich das auf Stream anguckt, auch wenn man halt Rank nicht wirklich mit guten Gegnern vergleichen kann,
die Koordine zusammenspielen, geht er da schon übertrieben.
Also geht da schon richtig ab teilweise.
Und das, obwohl er sich oftmals dank Chat und allem Drumherum plus halb auf das Game konzentrieren kann.
Und der zweite Punkt, warum ich mir gedacht hab, dass er auch richtig gut ist,
nicht nur einfach auf Stream ist, weil er in das Team gekommen ist.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass Seagull und XQC bloß bei Dallas gelandet sind, weil sie große Streamer sind.
Oder die größten Overwatch-Streamer.
Das war bestimmt teilweise auch mit dabei, aber beide sind auch richtig gut.
Alle, die Seagull vorher geflamed haben, so nach dem Motto Ranked Heroes und so was,
er hatte einfach Pech mit seinem ersten Team, aber der Kell an sich ist einfach übertrieben gut.
Weil er an sich nach einem der besten Overwatch-Spieler es gibt.
Vor allem kann er auch sau viele Helden spielen.
So, ich bin wieder da.
WB.
So, dann...
Ich gucke jetzt gerade mal.
Okay, da ist schon ein bisschen die Dudel offen.
Kannst du da hinweiten? Ich hoffe mal, das ist jetzt weg.
Ich hoffe auch, du hast neu gestartet.
Das hattest du doch aber noch nie.
Also, diesen Mikroruckler habe ich eigentlich nur mit verkorksten Nvidia-Treibern.
Hast du komplett neu install gemacht?
Diese Clean-Install-Geschichte, okay.
Dann queue ich mal.
Aber es kann halt auch wieder sein, ich weiß jetzt nicht, welche Windows-Version...
Der Richie schreibt, der hat seit heute das gleiche Probleme.
Ich habe seit heute das gleiche Problem mit deinem Kollegen, ihr kennt euch doch, oder?
Kennt ihr euch nett?
Das war der...
Der Richie war der, der ursprünglich Click-Effekt ins Leben gerufen hat.
Der der ursprünglich Tank gespielt hat.
Nee, das kann es sein.
Nee, ich glaube, ihr kennt euch gar nicht mehr.
Ihr seid so ein bisschen aneinander vorbei.
Du bist quasi hier aufgetaucht, aber er war schon wieder weg.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe keinen Bob-Man-Tank zu spielen, fällt mir gerade auf.
Darf ich Orisa spielen?
Carriesst du mich auch mit Orisa?
Mach mal.
Das ist halt nur das Problem, wenn dein Schild am Arsch ist, bist du meistens auch am Arsch.
Ja.
Deswegen kriege ich vielleicht ein bisschen Heal von der Mercy diesmal.
Mal gucken.
Weil es halt schon ärgerlich ist.
Es ist von einem Windows zum anderen, da hast du schon wieder neue Probleme.
Da kannst du nicht entscheiden, welches mehr broken ist, als das andere.
Ich bin aber sowas immer relativ empfindlich, was Input-Lang, irgendwelche Ruckler, Screen-Tearing und alle möglichen Sachen angeht.
Und ich muss sagen, seitdem ich diesen ganzen Game-Mode-Scheiß ausgeschaltet habe unter Windows,
ich habe keine Probleme.
Und wo du noch meintest, es liegt bestimmt an Windows, wo ich asynchronen Sound hatte.
Das lag nicht an Windows, das lag an OBS-Settings.
OBS-Settings musste ich use Timestamps ausschalten.
Die Mei flenkt uns, glaube ich, unten lang.
Ja, da ist sie, unter uns.
Mei ist fast...
Wir müssen runter.
Okay, ja, ja, ja.
Oh, die sind so low.
Was geht denn hier ab, ey?
Ich bin am Paylord.
Das ist doch noch ein Hanzo.
Okay, da konnte ich echt nicht mehr machen.
Das ist übelst räunig.
Ich habe aber das Gefühl, ich kann mit...
Ich weiß drauf.
Ich habe den Medibug Hanzo immer noch nicht gefixt, dass das Magazin rausguckt.
Die Mercy sagt, wir werden geregt.
Hat sie recht.
Mercy, was machst du da auch?
Ich habe sie.
Get rekt, Fahrer.
Schreckt.
Schreckt, rekt, Tyrannosaurus, rekt.
Wo ist denn unser Heiler, Mann?
Weiß nicht.
Dann bin ich jetzt auch auf...
Auf Roadhog wieder.
Alter, was ist hier los?
Das ist ein paar Hammer.
Habt ihr die Tracer?
Ja, ihr habt die Tracer.
Gut.
Das wird...
Wenn sie mich mal Damage boosten, ey.
Ich kenne so viele Leute.
Das wird Rissa.
Das ist echt schwierig.
Ich habe das Gefühl, mit Reinhardt hätte ich da auch am Arsch gewesen.
Ich bleibe mal am Paylord.
Warum stirbt ihr nicht?
Ich bin am Paylord, ich brauche Hilfe.
Rekt, Winston, rekt.
Das war zwar eine Solo-Ult.
Aber richtig 0, 0-3-D war das schon.
Ich bin am Paylord, ich konteste einfach und gucke, was ich hier kriege.
Hanzo.
Oben links ist was.
Ich habe nicht genau gesehen was.
Warum hat das denn nicht getroffen?
Wollt ihr mich rollen oder was?
Die haben das richtige Kackkomp, die Gegner.